What is SEO and why do we do it?
So I'm gonna go very basic here and some of you that are experts and have been doing this
for a long time, just bear with me, I'm all about the fundamentals because fundamentals
wins basketball games, ask John Wooden.
Okay, so SEO, I know this is very basic but S stands for search, E stands for engine,
O stands for optimization, search engine optimization.
In layman terms, it is taking a website and getting it to the top of Google.
Okay, that's it.
Very, very simple and there are certain things that we have seen and tested and proven, at
least in theory, that they will get you to the top of Google and I say that at least
in theory because nobody really knows the answers.
This is Google that's messing with us.
Google basically gives these little breadcrumbs and says, hey, this is what we say helps but
we don't actually know if that's true and it's just a big giant game for them but here
we are, we're playing the game because this traffic that will come from SEO is worth gold.
So this is the part where we are going to turn a deal into an asset and I'll tell you
right now if you're watching this video and you're like, hey, I don't really care about
the assets, I just want to have my deal at 1000 bucks or my deal at 1500, I'm gonna spend
the $300 or $400 or $600 on ads, I'm gonna make the difference, cool, shut this part
down and keep doing deals.
However, I would highly recommend you continue these modules, you continue watching, you
continue learning, you continue growing because if we can nail this part, this is where we
can get the website to rank at the top of Google and when a website ranks at the top
of Google, we start getting what's called organic traffic.
That is traffic where people will search for Concrete Queen Creek using our example and
they will look and find our website without us having to pay for ads, they will call us
without us having to pay for ads and therefore that traffic is essentially free, those are
free leads for us so it costs us $0 to acquire and then we can turn around and be charging
that same 1000, 2000.
So the game is very simple.
We're going to use SEO, we're gonna build up the website, we're gonna use SEO and we're
gonna rank it at the top of Google and as the organic calls start to come in, it's gonna
allow us to shut down the ads little by little and our organic continues to increase and
there's gonna be this shift so every time we decrease our ads by $10, we make an extra
$10 because our price stays the same.
We make $100 so we're doing this, okay?
I highly, highly, highly recommend doing this part of the process.
This is the final piece because this is where we go from a deal to an asset.
One of the other benefits of doing SEO, of getting your website ranked is it solidifies
the deal and it mitigates our risk.
What I mean by that is if we only have leads coming in from ads, we run the risk of Google
messing with the ads and us being affected.
But if we have leads coming in from SEO and the ads, if Google messes with the ads, well
we still have the SEO leads, right?
We still have the organic leads.
So doing this is going to solidify the deal and mitigate our risk.
What I've seen in my experience is the leads that come in from SEO, the organic leads,
meaning leads that weren't paid for by ads.
I don't know if this is actual fact, this is just my gut telling me, but it seems like
they're usually a little higher quality.
I don't know if it's because the buyer, the person that's searching for that service is
a little bit more savvy and they see the ads and they go, hey, you know, that's an ad which
means that that company paid to be there, I'm gonna go and look for the organic.
I don't know.
But pound for pound I have seen that the leads that come from organic seem to be a little
higher quality and by higher quality I mean they convert a little bit better.
Again, this is just a gut thing, but I really, really like the organic leads.
Even though we don't necessarily need them, they're super, super nice to have because
again they mitigate our risk and they just allow us to sleep better at night.
So guys, with that said, let's keep going.